[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, special relativity.
So we're starting a
new chapter in which
we look at tests
and implications
of special relativity.
We started the entire
discussion and evaluation
of Lorentz transformations
and the description
of the paradoxes based
on Einstein's postulates.
Those are not axioms, which
means that we do actually
have to verify.
They are a prediction
of how nature functions,
and experimental verification
is needed to gain confidence
that those postulates
are actually correct
or realized in nature.
And we have studied some
of those tests already.
And this serves as a little bit
of a review of the discussions
we had to this point.
One experimental test
is stellar aberration,
which we discussed can be
explained by special relativity
and by velocity addition.
So this gives us some
idea about what light is.
Light isotropy is being
tested in a variety
of different experiments,
starting from Michelson-Morley,
which basically tests
that the speed of light
is independent of the
orientation of the apparatus.
We have not discussed in
detail another experiment,
which is very similar.
It's the Kennedy and
Thorndike experiment,
which tests that
the speed of light
is also independent
of the velocity
of the apparatus itself.
As one of the
homework assignments,
we looked at de Sitter who
tested that the speed of light
is independent of the
speed of the source.
And that has been
tested, for example,
with the motion of binary
stars, as we did in our pset,
in our homework assignment.
We can look in particle
physics at the decay of a pion
into two photons.
And those pions, they can have
a lot of energy, for example,
with a beta of 0.999
times the speed of light.
And still the photons
are of this decay.
They behave like
any other photon.
They move with the
speed of light.
Let me discuss the Doppler
effect and relativistic Doppler
effect and analyze light
with various frequencies.
And one of the
hypotheses you could have
is that the photon actually
is a massive particle.
This would directly modify
Coulomb's laws, which
are tested experimentally.
And those results would be
dependent on the frequency.
There is weird
electromagnetic effect
if you introduce a mass
to the photons like torque
on a magnetic ring Again,
here precision measurements
have been performed.
And they're all in agreement
with the hypothesis
that the photon is massless.
And we talked about the Doppler
shift and redshift for light.
Another class of
experiment is where
we look directly
at time dilation,
for example, in the
decay of the muon.
As we discussed, we have
cosmic muons to study,
or we can produce muons
in the laboratory as well
and study them.
Or we can put very
precise clocks on planes,
fly them around the globe, and
compare them with stationary
and just simply measure the
effect of special relativity
on those clocks.
In all of this experimentation
and experimental verification,
it's important to understand
the importance of uncertainties
in the scientific
process overall.
I think that--
remember, when one
has the historic
perspective on science,
one often forgets that
a specific measurement
comes with an
uncertainty, often,
a statistical uncertainty
or systematic effects, which
are quite important to quantify
the level of verification
of the theoretical hypothesis.
One example here
is-- and experiments
can have biases as well.
And one example of
a biased experiment
is here one by
Walter Kaufmann who
tried to measure e/m,
the electric charge
over the mass of the electron.
But he had a rather
strong theoretical bias.
And he conducted the
experiment at the time Einstein
was proposing his theory.
The bias really came from
the model of an electron
at the time.
And, as experiments, they were
inconsistent with Einstein.
So he said Einstein is wrong.
Einstein and Lorentz are wrong.
Planck looked at
this and said maybe,
but Einstein's conclusion
immediately by looking at this
was, no, this cannot be.
And it took a little bit of
time to tee up those experiments
until 1940.
You can read more about this
in this Wikipedia article
about Walter
Kaufmann's experiments,
but let me just
read this to you.
"The prevalent results decidedly
speak against the correctness
of Lorentz's assumption,
as well as Einstein's.
If, on account of that, one
considers this basic assumption
refuted, then one
would be forced
to consider it a
failure to attempt
to base an entire field
of physics, including
electrodynamics and
optics, upon the principle
of relative movement."
We now know this was wrong,
but scientific process
happens in scientific
environment.
And I started this
class by explaining
that one needs to be open
minded to learn and to study
and to grow scientifically.
And one has to question
the assumptions,
understand the assumptions
when then go into measurements.
So this is the first
part of this chapter
where we talk about tests.
We will have a discussion
of implications
of special relativity
as we move on from here.